after Democratic presidential candidates
have held their second round of debates
today and tomorrow in Detroit
most of them will head to Nevada for a
series of campaign events it's also
where we joined voters for three meals
in one day it is part of a series we
will bring you every month until 2020
and that presidential election then CTM
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
back from her Nevada road trip to Rica
what did voters tell you well first I
have to say it's nice to get an
assignment where you get to eat as part
of what you have to do but on a serious
note the voters in Nevada we spoke with
we're saying a lot about immigration the
economy health care and student loans
several voters also talked about the
divisive nature of politics today Nevada
is the third state to hold a primary or
caucus and represents a diverse
electorate the state went for Hillary
Clinton by a slim margin in 2016 we
wanted to know more about what voters
are thinking about today
[Music]
we began our day at mom's diner and
perang having a known for the best
burgers in town they serve up with solid
breakfast to this community about an
hour west of Las Vegas was left with
acres of empty lots after the housing
crisis a decade ago but builders and
home buyers are back most of the
customers we met at Mom's lean
conservative you're very clear about
where you stand with you with your hat
and we're happy to tout an improved
economy you know there's more people
working in America right now than you've
ever been
I will definitely take some coffee thank
you very much
immigration was another issue that
mattered regardless of party I don't go
for an open border system at all this
group of church friends included an
independent a Republican and a Democrat
are you guys learning about each other
sort of political views for the first
time are there any Democrats that you
think could sway you to vote for a
Democrat in 2012
usually I vote Republican just because
I'm a Christian and there's some if
there's some policies as far as abortion
and things I just I'll never vote for
somebody who's you know Pro those things
who do you like right now nice to live
them Delaware
so other than just living in Delaware
what is it about him that right now he's
got you everything that people don't
like about it you know Biden to me is a
straight shooter
between communities here in Nevada are
vast stretches of open land as you can
see about 85% of this land is owned by
the federal government
government controls too much of the land
in Nevada way to that argument enjoyed
bipartisan support at the muddy River
Bar and Grill in rural mawatha how are
you where we met up with a group of
retirees during lunch being retired I'm
concerned about prices going up and our
retirement to stay in Social Security
why prescription prices are so high and
so I think that's a concern for all
seniors what are your thoughts on
integration the biggest problem we have
as far as that is concerned we're not
making it so people can come in legally
I mean the paperwork is humongous the
one thing that still bothers me is that
people still refer to me as a Mexican
I'm an American kid comes from Germany
learns English nobody has asked him you
know where are you from because there's
a stereotype of what an American it
looks like
Southern Nevada is considered one of the
sunniest places in the country and
harvesting that energy has been key to
the Paiute Tribe which is the first to
build a solar field on native land this
2,000 acre field serves more than
100,000 customers the coal plant that
once operated here was imploded earlier
this month are you glad this coal plant
yes yes I'm glad as it we're on their
way to a new economy people have to give
up on this Vicki Simmons is the chairman
of the Moapa band of Paiutes maybe these
solar projects will do some good and
save some rice in the future we the
reservation lies about 50 miles north of
our final stop las vegas nevada x'
biggest and most diverse city
we stopped for dinner at Vinita Michiyo
calm a Mexican restaurant and a local
favorite as colorful as anything on this
trip hello how are you
this group of friends were visiting from
California two of them will vote for
president for the first time in 2020
what issues concern you all of us right
now
mainly student loans probably it's set
up in a way where it kind of screws a
person over at the end you know student
debt is a concern for many young voters
how are you but here like everywhere we
went on this day in Nevada the
conversation ultimately turned to
immigration a top issue in this state
that's nearly 30 percent Hispanic I
would say right now
immigration is like one of the biggest
issues the voters we met in Las Vegas
were as politically diverse as you could
see just like the city itself so there's
good reason for the state that you'll
see nearly all those Democratic
challengers end up in that state
probably by the end of this week and
it's a battleground state its diverse
30% of the population is Hispanic so the
the challengers know that they have to
go to places like that to really get a
sense of where they stand right now I
feel informed by your piece and now I'm
hungry the question how's the food it
was all delicious delicious we'll be
planting heart surgery Kay thank you
very much we'll be right back